Speaker 1: Let's go next to Steph from Wisconsin.
Steph, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Well, Heidi, so I actually had
a question kind of following up the person
who went before the Spartanburg person, OK,
and it's about media literacy.
So do you think it's possible to get to a
level of media literacy that the majority
of American people would be able to watch
something like Fox News and understand that
much of what they've reported on is actually
just opinions?
Speaker 1: I think yes, because a majority
just means 51 percent, and I think that's
achievable.
I think that's achievable.
I think that if you said 80 percent, you know,
if we got to sort of propaganda herd immunity
for lack of a better term, where enough people
would understand that you don't want to signal
boost Fox News because then it just spreads
like a virus, I think 80 percent would be
tough.
But, yeah, I think we could.
I mean, listen, I think 35 to 40 percent of
the country already gets it.
So I don't think that it's unreasonable to
think we could get to to majority level.
Yeah.
Speaker 5: OK, and do you think it's mainly
passed down like I guess not passed down,
but if it is media literacy primarily taught
in schools or within family social circles,
what
Speaker 1: I wish it were more taught in school.
But unfortunately, I think that there are
parents who very either explicitly but sometimes
implicitly with other things, teach kids to
think for themselves, but also to understand
whether their beliefs are based on something
solid or something flimsy.
And so I, I think it would be great if media
literacy was actually being learned and taught
in school more frequently.
Unfortunately, I don't think it is.
And it really depends on on what's going on
at home.
And unfortunately, what's going on at home
is not so good for a lot of people.
And that's why I've been advocating that media
literacy and critical thinking and epistemology
would ideally start being taught at age 11
to everybody at 10, 11, 12, somewhere in their.
Speaker 5: You think that late?
Speaker 1: I mean, I think it can do things
you I think earlier than that, you can do
you can do things, I think, in third, fourth
grade, but it would have a little bit of a
different flavor and tone.
I think they would be precursors, precursors.
But like real media literacy, probably early
middle school.
Yeah.
From what I've read.
Speaker 5: OK, that's interesting, yeah.
One last question, would producer Pat start
and only fans
Speaker 1: OK, well, we will talk with what
are you looking to see on the only fans, I
guess, is the question.
I could I could talk to him about it.
Speaker 5: Yeah, ask him about maybe him doing
hot yoga.
Speaker 1: OK, all right, stuff very good.
We will look into that and report back.
Speaker 5: OK, perfect.
All right.
Speaker 1: There's stuff from Wisconsin very,
very interested in the producer, Pat.
Only fans.
All right.
That's too crazy to call.
So let's take a quick break.
We will regroup, lets things calm down.
If you're holding, don't hang up because I'm
going right back to the phones momentarily.